[Music]
Camilla Rose loves to dance
the little girl on the right of your
screen
she's with her sister Florence
they all Just Dance and play in the
front room
and then
a Saturday we get us up
and um
she was sick and this is Camilla Rose
right now
she's on a ventilator in intensive care
struck down with group a strep just a
week ago her dad says it's a miracle
she's still alive there was pneumonia
to Mr pneumonia in a chest he still got
into a bull stream and the strippers
kicked in as well because she had two
viruses and
she's still she's still no no no one
here at the woods she's really really
poor
remember when she got here Monday they
said she was the most peeliest girl in
all of England
it's a just to go off and dancing on a
Friday night with her friends so in a
little bit on the weather sat there
they've done a bit more about Sunday but
to go to the hospital I told she's only
got a bit of a wheezy's kick chest
to them basically
just not going to have the same girl
anymore I reckon because he used to live
it's such a special little girl
how special she was she was every every
child special
and every parent's jobs special to them
and they were all the separate Wares but
she was so special
I still haven't seen good night
Camilla Rose is under the expert care of
doctors here at Liverpool's older hey
Children's Hospital
group a strep is a common winter
infection
this Hospital like others is seeing more
serious cases than usual the vast
majority of children will recover
without any ill effect whatsoever
However unfortunately a small number of
children each year will go on to develop
more serious and invasive disease it's
probably in the region of under five
percent of children that would go on to
develop a more serious infection
group a strep is caused by bacteria
which affects the nose throat and lungs
known as group a Streptococcus it can
spread through coughs sneezes and skin
to skin contact
the symptoms can include a fever a rash
or flushed cheeks
four-year-old Ibrahim Muhammad Ali died
at the beginning of November
and this Primary School in Wales lost
one of its young pupils to the infection
last week
in every given year there will be a
given number of invasive group a
Streptococcus disease
they can be very severe and in cases
tragic cases which result in death of
the individual we are looking into we
are investigating and if there is
anything that we need to do over and
above what we do normally we will be
doing
Camilla Rose has her parents by her
bedside praying for a full recovery
they're desperate to see their little
girl dance again
Ashish Joshi Sky News